تتقدم هذه السيده بايداع ملف ترشحها باحدى
الدوائر الانتخابيه في العاصمه التونسيه
في وقت يرصد فيه الملاحظون ضعفا في ترشح
المراه للاستحقاق البرلماني
تونس واحد استقبال الثاني
ات المحدوده للنساء والعقليه
وخوفنا ان يكون المشهد السياسي القادم
الذكوري بنتياز الدستور الخامس والعشرين
على سعيد دوله لتحقيق التناسب بين المراه
والرجل في المجالس المنتخب الا ان
المرسومه عدد 50 ناقض ما جاء في الدستور
يعني رجوع الى الوراء في علاقه بتمثيل
النساء
في الحياه السياسيه
وضرب حقا مقتصا هو تناسب في القائمه
الانتخابيه
اعتبرت ان رئيسه الحكومه بصفتها رئيسه
مجلس النضارات
بين المراه والرجل قد فوتت فرصه التدخل
لتلقيح المرسوم الانتخابي حسب مقترح تقدمت
به الجمعيه في الخامس اكتوبر في انه فرصه
تاريخيه كان بالامكان اقتناسها انه نعتمد
بمبدا الاقتراع الزوجي على الافراد وبك
يفترض فقط اعاده تقسيم الدوائر انه يقع
دمج الدوائر فيكون على كل دائره شخصين
وبالتالي الترشح يكون زوجي بين الرجل
والمراه بالضروره سيكونوا المجس متناسق
وتر النشيطه النسويه في تونس ان ما جاء في
مرسوم الانتخابات من الغاء التمويل
العمومي سيكون عائقا للنساء اكثر من
الرجال
في المستقبل
حوريات لانه النساء اللي يعرفوا حاجات
النساء ويوسوها في البرلمان وبالتالي
تغيير السياسات الوطنيه والمحليه لا يمكن
ان تكون دون وجود نساء في مثل هذه المجالس
تعتبر المدافعات عن حقوق المراه انهن
خسرنا ما تم تحقيقهم من مكتسبه سابقه في
تمثيليه النساء وان البرلمان المرتقب
سيكون الذكوريا المدرسه